[Music]
and too dumb to parent news Oh a lot of
people submitted by greetings from
Norway Oh Norway I don't know no way
with your fjords [ __ ] open-faced
sandwiches a couple who were previously
deemed unfit to parent due to their low
IQ have regained fathers in custody of
their associate what so they make
parents take IQ tests yeah well maybe
cuz they [ __ ] up some way somehow and
then they had to take the test it was
because one person complained that they
weren't attentive enough and then so
they made them take IQ tests and so the
average IQ ranges from 90 to 110 the mom
scored 72 and the dad scored 66 oh
actually like this I feel like to be a
parent you should have to take a
parenting test and maybe not IQ bit yeah
more like common sense like if your
friends ask you to go to the club and
your kids 1 years old what do you do you
have no babies like I'll be like well
obviously I would you know yeah but
there's people that still can't even
pass that like there's even like on that
like the firearms test a lot of us
comment Centene when you find a gun on
the floor do you put the tip of the gun
in your mouth and pull the trigger
of course there's some people don't
actually fail that [ __ ] so I think like
if they can at least have that then half
the people that shouldn't be having kids
in this situation probably at least like
50% of the idiots
what is the IQ of somebody who is
slightly mentally challenged because if
it's like 60 and 70s are really close
number to that I think that test is that
determinate anything below that is
mentally challenged oh [ __ ] that's why
they're saying if you have to mentally
challenged parents it's a danger what
does this IQ test consists of they're
like it's like that thing where if you
judge a fish's intelligence on how he
climbs a tree you know like one person
might not necessarily know all the
acquirement [ __ ] es officially returning
the ship back to the betcha
some like super like super super
kick-ass Alabama purrs and that's it
you're like logic tests they're just
problem-solving yeah it's not all
language base because sometimes it's
shapes too in colors a lot of his shapes
and colors so it'd be like a triangle
right like a black triangle just like
the kids toy which one of these shapes
go in their circle so because before it
was biased she'd be fit with that type
of confidence to circle I would say like
maybe in the 60s or 70s it was biased
because they would have questions like
do you first put the duvet in this or
whatever in that which order but then
minorities would be like what is a duvet
I don't even know no I don't know I
don't even have a blanket yeah but then
now they change the IQ test to be more
universal and not so based on they
should ask the real question for an
Asian person which side of the furry
blanket is more soft the bright code or
the dog we all would have known is there
a tiger or a bear on it Oh a tiger one I
had the tiger had two roses I had the
Koala and the roses I had a brown koala
one that [ __ ] was no [ __ ] that [ __ ] is
so comfortable so warm you know I need a
new one my I have one that's all black
it's like any put it in the dryer they
got fry no it's actually it's it's
hanging on there but like some of the
fuzzy pieces assertive Fox I've had it
for more than ten years damn I need to
get that [ __ ] from back home dude
I'm sorry using this oh it's so tacky
looking here mom knows where to get a
mat I gotta go to Tijuana and at the
border they're selling it on the side
just go to any flea market man that's
true how they're just hanging on their
alleys mm-hmm yeah so this couple here
someone complained that they weren't
attentive enough so their kids cuz they
have a four year old and an eleven month
old that's pretty low IQ they're like 60
and 70 yeah but I guess what they're
arguing is like I don't need to be
intelligent to be a good parent you
don't have to be intelligent but you
can't be the r-word and you have to be
really fun company yeah you have to be
competent yeah with good common sense
I feel like there's even intelligent
people who just don't [ __ ] have any
common sense whatsoever so this guy can
be a [ __ ] genius based on his IQ
yeah it probably does know how to take
care of it you should do that on both
ends of the spectrum like
if your IQ is too high this needs to be
like common sense type stuff a hard
thing to test I do smoke cigarettes
while you're splashing gasoline on
yourself
probably not let me think about that I
don't know though if you know animals
can have kids and all that stuff but
they don't live in a civilization and
they rape each other to steal from each
other that's okay it's instinct we're
just glad they get their kids back like
what deemed unfit suddenly since they've
gotten their kids taken away for so long
because it was about four years oh yeah
nothing is that the second kid was born
like right away they took them away
oh damn yeah too stupid after all this
time they've been having like supervised
visits and then they observe how well
they parent these kids and if they're
capable of even raising them on their
own and so apparently after all this
time they found that they are able to
raise them on their own it it's not just
IQ base we're assuming that because they
have low IQ they are also not discipline
people but that's not that's not you
can't assume that like they might be
really disciplined and you know yeah
because they're saying during those
supervised visits that they cited minor
parenting deficiencies including that
reading enough to the kids during the
supervised visits or giving or taking
away treats as a method of discipline
and alternating who played with the boys
during their 5-hour visits at the state
office like apparently those were the
minor parenting deficiencies no one read
to me I feel like I've failed all of
them yeah no one read to me read to me
either
I had to read by myself yeah so they're
just saying like these are ordinary
things that people do on a daily basis
is not like enough to get your kids
thinking away okay for years what the
[ __ ] obviously where was this at Oregon
Oregon I went to the Huntington
librarianship and I saw I still never
been there you know but it's just a nice
place especially to take tyka and stroll
just walk around it's really [ __ ]
nice yeah there's this I saw a couple
with kids and his dad had a picnic
blanket and he had the kid on slab and
he was reading the kid a book
are they white yeah of course course
that cause like God like I always
thought oh she's on TV I saw a person do
it and this kid was just like so happy
like you was on drugs
yes like when you reads to him like
looking at the pictures and he's just
like oh I'm just imagine like the
perfect like red checkerboard basket
with a little wicker I mean a blanket
with a whisker basket and like just I'm
just gonna read him like [ __ ] Tupac
lyrics and [ __ ] that'd be tight
that's what Amy and Eric
was the baby leaves the other way well
they're late blow out the faces anyway
from yeah so here's a newborn
they don't look Dom they look like an OG
[ __ ] creep past couple or so my guys
go G ganks a couple though Oh as long as
they're sweet to the kid and they're
trying I'm in like IQ isn't everything
yeah yeah you know you can't assume
intent and everything based off of IQ
because they're saying like the kids are
safe like being made sure that they were
taking care of like there were no safety
that was the alarming thing that I want
to know and I don't know that either
it's just like because if it's like
minor things and they could take her kid
away that's crazy
it was like you put the baby in the oven
and you turn it on or something like
that that's pretty crazy their neighbors
are probably like [ __ ] abusing the
[ __ ] allocated no one's looking at them
like their neighbors are annoyed of them
or something and then they use it as a
way or maybe they just didn't like them
having too much fun
ball faces yeah well luckily they have
their kids back now I didn't know you
could take kids away just because just
from IQ mm-hmm that stays weird or again
like you guys [ __ ] other crazy [ __ ]
why are you like a lot of people who
have high IQ but they're lazy as [ __ ] so
that IQ doesn't go and like it doesn't
even get used
oh yeah that's true too they take that
into consideration I wonder if
any type of test like parents like
laziness test yeah I think they should
take over they should take away kids for
laziness more than IQ true and they
should also just sterilize people who
have a past of hooking up their kids for
sure
cuz there are some dumbass parents like
my mom but works really hard
mm-hmm she was proud of her IQs for
lasagna if there was an organ
I wanna got taken away did she do IQ
score yeah she told me I think she took
it when she was in college I was 80
oh that on the low end or normal I think
one thing there's normal low end but she
worked really hard to provide which it
could provide from the other single mom
and she did a really good job but she
was proud of her eighty yeah I feel like
it's cuz your mom is too like Confucius
for [ __ ] because the question would be
like does their circle go to this
triangle well it depends what is the
material made other mean it is the
spirit of the mind imagination not real
didn't say going that does she take the
IQ test and Taiwan's yeah I think so yes
oh it's all gonna say if she took it
here maybe her English wasn't that great
just like she was like the only reason I
was good at math is because I memorized
it all well she didn't actually learn
well that's most Asian teaching though
in math I've never taken the time pretty
sure mine is roughly about a lo 76
what's the highest like Einstein and all
the genius like 150 or so huh I think I
started like 180 or something but
there's people that are up to 200
there's those dumbass people who are
like their IQ might be high but every
time like they get into an argument with
anyone they just miss you dude like well
I have an IQ of 142 so I know what I'm
talking about the [ __ ] 142 IQ but
emotional intelligence is 61
it's important to brag about their IQ
like by IQ or like the same people who
are like I am a member of Mensa
I'll still kick your ass that's what a
low IQ person Instagram bio member of
Mensa
congratulations [ __ ] she says what is
men sighs oh really yeah it's like a
genius commando it's a high IQ committee
yeah but it's also like bragging about
like well I'm a Yelp elite it's
basically [ __ ] bad you know cuz Mensa
sounds like a really dope tampon for men
yeah working because I I think I've
taken those IQ online tests but I heard
that they're not good you gotta go to
like a legit institution and I want to
take one I want to know we'll go get
some DNA yeah or we'll take it together
and then we'll just tear ours up after I
think the online ones are pretty close
to range though like you'll be like ten
points to fifteen points off is that big
little ten fifteen so a big pretty big
like 92 it's a [ __ ] like 70 something
it's not it's I mean the categories have
ranges so you'll still be within the
same cat like if you know if you're like
smart or genius or dumb or the r-word
like you'll still fall within those yeah
[Music]